hello
conspiracy theorists deplorables
and decent hard-working americans how
you doing people
it's december 2nd 2020. that's right
it's 1202
2020. i'm dave rubin this is the reuben
report direct message
i am fired up today uh you know a few of
you have noted
via emails and uh youtube comments and
on the reuben report community a few
other places
that i seem to be a little more fired up
lately than usual i've dropped some
colorful language a couple
f-bombs every now and again and i think
just generally
speaking i i am more fired up and a
little more
i don't know i guess a little more i
have a little more righteous indignation
than i normally would have because we
are just watching
just an endless cascade of stupidity
and dishonest drivel being dropped on us
by
our political elite and our mainstream
media
and it's just endless and as someone
that has to talk about it and has to
know about it and everything else
it can it can start driving you a little
nuts that being said
i'm loving what i'm doing here and i
love that you guys are loving it so
it's all good uh but yes if you've seen
a little bit of a different
shift in me as we've watched the world
go completely nuts since the election
because
if you thought it was nuts before the
election it's just been absolutely
nuttier since
uh well then i guess that shift is real
and here we are and i'm glad that you're
with me
on the adventure uh okay we got three
stories for you today uh before we get
into that real quick guys uh we are
doing an end of year giveaway we've got
a bunch of merch
that we're looking to move so if you
join reubenreport.com over the next
couple days this is just while supplies
last we've got
a couple hundred left over we've got
mugs and t-shirts reuben report mugs and
t-shirts if you join reubenreport.com
and then uh you email your
username to support reubenreport.com
we're gonna send you a reuben report mug
or a reuben report shirt you don't know
what you're gonna get but you're gonna
get one or the other
you have to be a paid subscriber so
again all you do you sign up
and just forward your screen name your
username over to
support reubenreport.com we're going to
get that mug
or that shirt out to you immediately all
right so
the three stories that i want to cover
today uh i think they're all pretty
pretty perfect and right within the lane
that i like to talk about here because
they're all sort of the confluence
of media and politics first off
james o'keefe of project veritas they've
been working on this for months
so what they did was cnn has these
conference calls every morning led by
the president of the network jeff zucker
who basically
they have this talk where they can chime
in and everyone can sort of
figure out what the stories of the day
are what angle they want to pursue
what messaging they want to get out
there well somehow o'keefe and project
veritas were able to get
on these calls and they've been
recording them for months
and there was actually a hilarious video
that o'keefe put out yesterday where he
in fact chimes in on one of the calls
and says hey
zucker how you doing it's me james
o'keefe and we've recorded all this
stuff
it's pretty great and then zucker kind
of scrambles real quick and gets off
but anyway they've they've released a
bunch of this so we're going to play a
compilation about a two-minute
compilation of some of that
and i think you'll really see the way
cnn doesn't
report the news meaning remain neutral
and report what's happening
but they actually try to editorialize
everything every day and they're they're
having meetings saying
how they're gonna frame things so it
fits their narrative so we're gonna play
that
and then you'll decide what you think
how about that crazy right
uh then the second story um you know
president-elect guy with broken foot
with dementia joe biden
um his nominee for treasury secretary is
janet yellen
and she was on video just a day or two
ago saying that she's going to use the
treasury department
to address racial inequality gender
disparities and the climate crisis so
we're going to show you the video
and then unpack that a little bit
because you know i had a lot of my my
good liberal friends
who were saying oh we must get rid of
orange man
but joe biden will stand up to the
radical left well meanwhile
what do we have now we have the incoming
potentially incoming i'm still not so
sure of it
potentially incoming treasury secretary
saying that they're going to use the fed
in essence to deal with racial
inequality that kind of sounds like
reparations doesn't it
gender disparities well the gender paid
gap doesn't exist you guys know that and
we'll talk about that
and the climate crisis i have no idea
what that has to do uh
with the treasury department so very
bizarre and yes
if you were a good liberal who thought
that uh voting joe biden would stop the
radical lefties uh i hate to tell you
but there's a fly in your soup
and and third we got a crazy
long list of hypocritical democratic
politicians i've been asking people on
twitter can someone
get me the master list of these
ridiculous
awful progressive politicians who lock
us down destroy our livelihoods crush
our businesses
cause people to be uh drinking more and
have higher rates of
suicide and depression and all of these
things can you get me a list of these
people who are breaking their own rules
and twitter does not disappoint so we
got a great list
of and i'm going to read them all and
they there are some real
doozies but before we get to all that
guys today's episode
is brought to you by glint pay i've been
talking to you talking to you guys about
glen pay i've got my mock-up card right
there don't try to steal that number
it's not a real one
uh it's a really awesome way of getting
into the gold game you know i know
everybody's kind of feeling weird about
the economy right now and what's going
on with the us dollar and it feels like
everything's a little up in the air
well gold has been around for a long
time and
and it's pretty reliable that's what
they tell me
you can use glintpay your glint pay card
to either pay for your purchases
in gold or you can actually pay for your
purchases
in u.s dollars just like you would with
a debit card it's pretty fantastic
backed by
mastercard i've bought things on amazon
i've bought
nike products on nike.com i bought all
sorts of stuff you can go to starbucks
and use it
basically anywhere you can use your
credit card you can use glenpay you can
also buy
and sell gold it's pretty fantastic so
the glen card is issued by sutton bank
which is a member of the fdic
pursuant to license from mastercard
international
it's free to sign up so go to
glenpay.com ruben for more info
and to start purchasing gold today
that's glintpay.com
reuben to get your goal today and now
back to me and by the way guys of course
when you support our sponsors
you support my ability to uh to just
talk about the things that i want to
talk about without any
outside influence so it's always
appreciated appreciated all right
so let's talk about the first story uh
this project veritas
expose on these cnn morning calls i
think you're going to see that they're
doing a little more
than reporting on the news and remaining
objective
here is about a two-minute compilation
clip from the last few months
of what cnn jeff zucker cnn president
jeff zucker
has been uh telling his employees each
and every morning
okay i i just want to re-emphasize that
uh
you know i i think we we cannot
normalize
what has happened here uh in the last
week
with trump and his behavior and i i go
back to what
david said david chalian said that this
is a president who knows he's losing he
knows he's in trouble
uh is sick maybe
is uh on on the after effects of
steroids or not i don't know
but he is acting erratically and
desperately
and we we need to uh
uh we need to we need to not normalize
that
you know this is what we've come to
expect
for the last three and a half years four
years but
it clearly is exacerbated by
uh the time that we're in and the issues
that he's dealing with
and i think that we cannot just let let
it be
normalized he is all over the place and
acting erratically
and i think we need to lean into that
the
the trump media uh you know
moves immediately from okay well never
mind that unmasking was
you know uh found to be completely
non-testical
just to the latest uh uh alleged scandal
and uh expect everybody to just follow
suit so uh
i i don't think that we should be
repeating unsubstantiated
uh smears just because the right-wing
media suggests that we should
frankly if we've made any mistakes that
our banners have been too
uh polite and and we need to go well
after lindsey graham
there's a ton going on but stay strong
let's say newsy let's stay urgent like
let's be smart there is a lot of news
out there
and lindsey graham really deserves it
each of these so-called
scandals for trump each of these things
we should just once again
be careful to say that this is the one
that
is going to undo him with his voters and
to respond to
david chalian's
points about politics
i don't know why we would expect any of
these politicians to have a conscience
and or expect the politics wouldn't be
completely hypocritical and for us to
expect anything else
would be naive all right so let me do
the cleanup job here first which is that
this is just the stuff this is obviously
a small compilation of the stuff that
project veritas is leaking out
so could there be stuff that is against
the democrats
and against joe biden and against the
obama machine and against
kamala harris and bernie sanders and the
rest of it there could be did any of
that get seen to light
no but i think it's pretty obvious from
the way that they talk about trump i
mean some of the things we cannot
normalize trump and his behavior he's
sick
maybe he's on the effect of steroids
that was right after trump came out of
the hospital
after having covid i mean these types of
things we cannot normalize his behavior
when he says
this thing about the banners should
maybe even be a little more aggressive
in essence talking about lindsey graham
lindsey graham really deserves it we
cannot normalize these things and and a
bunch of other stuff
i think what you can see is that clearly
these people
are democrats like is there any chance
is there any chance
even without having full context meaning
i don't think o'keefe released
every single day the completely unedited
footage of anything
is there any doubt that these people
were anti-trump and anti-republican and
wanted to frame things in a certain way
right
so if you're a reporter and i think this
is why cnn gets more crap than any of
the other networks
it's like msnbc it's obviously lefty
fox news it's obviously on the right
there's no doubt about it
cnn is pretending to be nothing while it
obviously
leans left so people think of cnn or
from the old days of cnn you think of it
and this is what you should think of
journalism by the way because this is
what journalism is supposed to be
it's supposed to be that they report on
what happens not give you a lens
on what happens right that's what news
is now i always say i'm not a journalist
what i'm trying to do is
every day i wake up there's a couple
stories here i discuss it with my guys
and then i tell you about those stories
and i give you my opinion i am not
pretending to be a journalist on the
ground i am taking the information that
other
people report the happenings of the
world and i'm telling you what what
i think i think it's very obvious where
my biases may lie and you guys know
about my political evolution and
everything else that that's how you do
something
roughly honestly i believe okay and i'm
not pretending to be something
that i'm not but what cnn is basically
saying there what zucker is saying is
we have to present these stories through
a certain lens
as opposed to say this is what happened
this is what trump said
this is what the other guys said we are
presenting it
because this is what journalism is but
we have to be careful not to
make trump look this way and maybe don't
say this and we should say more of this
and i think that the average person has
just caught on to the game
you know it again it's like is wolf
blitzer a democrat or a republican is
jake tapper a democrat or a republican
is don lemon a democrat or republican is
chris cuomo
a democrat or a republican is brian
stelter a democrat or republican is
acosta what's his first name jim acosta
is he
a democrat or a republican it's like all
of these people you know they're all
democrats and i think just seeing it's
just all this is is peeling off another
layer of the onion
into all of these headlines basically
cnn headlines basically are the onion at
this point
but this is just peeling off another
layer and just seeing how they craft the
news
and by the way i don't know that there
is a perfect way to report news anymore
i don't know that there is because if
someone just reported
straight up news unbiased news
would anyone even watch it i don't know
because i'm gonna go out on a limb here
and assume that when cnn looks at their
ratings
that the bias stuff the crazed
anti-trump stuff that that probably gets
many more
uh views than the other stuff and that
that is a problem
and i think it's something that we're
going to have to deal with it's going to
become a bigger
and bigger problem as as the years go by
because as long as the internet remains
roughly free and i'm not so sure how
long that'll be
we are all going to figure out ways to
go to people who
either confirm our biases or see the
world more similarly
uh or in a similar fashion as we do and
that is
a problem and i don't know that there is
really any good answer
for it but this is actually a perfect
segue for the second segment because
what happens is we have a media that
doesn't report
honestly on what is happening here so i
think it was
fairly obvious to anyone that was paying
attention really and that was being
remotely honest in the last couple years
but especially in the last year the
election year
that what was happening with the biden
thing was that they were basically just
pushing through this old guy who kind of
reminded
people of the old days because people
are upset about covid and some people
don't like trump and they and all the
democrats decided to do
was let's take an old guy who's never
really
done anything like what is joe biden
really did he's always yelling about the
things that he's done but never really
did anything in government
for 47 years which by the way i don't
want government to do that much so i'm
okay with the people that do nothing if
you told me the politicians were doing
nothing going forward that would be
pretty much just fine with me but the
idea of biden was he'll be the one that
will remind people of the old days and
will get him in
and everything will sort of be okay and
then you had some people i
would include myself in this who were
warning no what this guy is actually
going to do
is he is just the host for the alien in
his belly that will burst forth and that
alien
is the progressive left okay that alien
is the radical marxist that alien is
the squad and the socialists and all of
these things and it's very obvious that
that is what is going to happen and you
can see it
by the way and you can just see that
they're tearing up you know they want to
get back into the iran deal
we've had no war we've had no war in
four years we're going to start going to
wars again that's going to be exciting
you can see that they want to deal with
all of the
to look at all of the issues through the
lens
that the left has been pushing but don't
take my word for it that's the point
don't take my word for it that this is
going to be a radical administration
let's listen to biden's nominee for
treasury treasury secretary
janet yellen because she says it here
herself
inaction will produce a self-reinforcing
downturn
causing yet more devastation
and we miss we risk missing the
obligation
to address deeper structural problems
inequality stagnant wages
especially for workers who lack a
college education
communities that have seen industry
disappear
with no good jobs replacing lost ones
racial disparities in pay job
opportunities
housing food security and small business
lending
that deny wealth building to communities
of color
gender disparities that keep women out
of the workforce
and keep our economy from running at
full
force it's a convergence of tragedies
that is not only economically
unsustainable
but one that betrays our commitment to
giving every american
an equal chance to get ahead
but i know this team will never give up
that commitment
as you've said before mr president-elect
out of our collective pain as a nation
we will find collective purpose to
control the pandemic
and build our economy back better than
before
to rebuild our infrastructure and create
better jobs
to invest in our workforce to advance
racial equity and make sure the economic
recovery
includes everyone to address the climate
crisis
with american ingenuity and american
jobs
working together with the outstanding
national security and foreign policy
team
you announced last week to help restore
america's global leadership
all right i want to be very clear with
my words here very careful with my words
here
so uh that is a bunch of [ __ ]
that is a bunch of [ __ ] that is
absolutely
perfect progressive democrat policy
because it
takes a bunch of buzzwords and actually
says nothing right so there's so much
there so she talks about racial
inequality and that we should have
racial equity now let's just be very
clear about this
very clear and correct me if i'm wrong
commenters
there are no laws in the united states
that stop you from doing
anything based on the color of your skin
you can become a small business owner
you can become
a doctor you can become a civil servant
you can become a youtuber
and you can become an nba basketball
star you can become
absolutely anything you want and
the government has no laws that stop you
from doing that now
if you were to say that i know some of
you were going to say this well actually
dave there are some laws that stop you
from doing this because we have things
like affirmative action
and that once people are caught in a
cycle of poverty meaning the government
starts giving them stuff
it's very hard to get out of that cycle
of poverty so i would say yes at some
level that is a type of systemic racism
but that ain't what these people are
talking about right they want to expand
these programs
that will keep people uh in the cycle of
poverty
also racial equity what does that mean
what does that really mean like are we
trying to make sure
that everyone regardless of any of their
skills
any of the things that they were taught
by their family or behaviors or anything
that will all
end up in the same place what does that
really mean i mean that is far more
communist than it is capitalist but by
the way
this is exactly what they were telling
us that they were going to usher in
let's not forget
that video that kamala harris put up two
days i think before the election
where she said that in america everyone
will end up at the same place what does
that mean so
if you work very hard you will end up at
the same place as the guy who doesn't
work hard
the word equity is the most dangerous
word that we have
flying in in our lexicon right now our
collective
lexicon okay this is this is a bad word
because equity is not what a society can
give you a society can give you equality
and we have done that incredibly well in
the united states
she also talks about gender disparities
that we have gender disparities
that apparently the treasury secretary
is supposed to deal with now
let's be very clear about this and i
would welcome you all don't take my word
for it when you're done with this video
uh prageru has an incredible video done
by my friend christina hoff summers
on the gender pay gap and guess what
guys it's a
myth men and women choose different
careers for different reasons
men generally are more interested in
things and women are more interested in
people
this is just a fact of biology doesn't
mean one is better than the other
so men and women choose different things
women also have children so then often
decide that that's a part of their life
that they want to spend at home
to then raise children by the way that's
a good thing that's a great thing
my mom worked before she had children
then she was a housewife
and made sure that we all went to school
with with lunch
you know lunch bags packed and she was
home when we got there and then when me
my brother and my sister
were all old enough my mom went back to
work and she became a teacher
okay now everyone can make all of those
choices my dad at the time was working
full-time every day and commuting into
new york city
and he made more of the money but
everyone makes their own choices and men
and women just
make different choices by the way in
sweden
and check this out again check it out
for yourself sweden where they've had a
wonderful egalitarian society for so
long no one
no one in their right mind thinks
sweden's uh a sexist society except the
radical lefties
well they they figured it out they saw
that okay men and women can do whatever
they want they've been doing it this way
for 30 years and they
and you know what the result was well
more men became engineers and more women
became nurses that's just what people
chose to do no one forced men
to become engineers and women to become
nurses but then what happens is
at the end of that the social justice
warriors and the radical lefties look at
that
and they go oh that must because be
because of systemic racism
or systemic sexism in this case and
it's like no we let the experiment go
the experiment was if we give people
equality will people make choices for
themselves
and the answer was yes the answer was
yes people made choices for their own
lives
and now they want to go back in and
re-engineer it and in essence what they
want to do is
force more women to become engineers and
force more men
to become nurses it's it's lunacy but
also
when they talk about racial inequality
like what are they saying what are they
saying that
i mean was that their sort of in on
saying we should have
reparations well no one in my family
ever owned slaves and even if someone in
my family did own slaves generations ago
i'm not guilty
for my parents sins or anyone else
before me sins and by the way either is
anyone else
uh and there is no one alive today that
was a slave in the united states
obviously right and it's like what are
they really trying to tell us
i think it's fairly obvious that all of
the radical lefty stuff that a bunch of
us were warning about
it's all being smuggled in through
through 78 year old broken foot joe
biden
but i i thought let me let me see maybe
i'm not understanding something here
maybe maybe the secretary of the
treasury is supposed to do a lot of this
stuff so i googled it what is the job
of the secretary of the treasury and and
here it is for you we're even going to
put it on the screen
the secretary of the treasury acts as a
principal advisor to the president
and the cabinet on economic issues the
united states department of the treasury
which the secretary oversees performs
many important functions
including paying the nation's bills
printing money
and collecting taxes paying the nation's
bills
okay that means if we borrow money from
somebody we got to pay it back although
we're not very good at that we're in a
lot of debt
uh printing money we often print money
even when we don't have it and
collecting taxes i wish they would just
collect less and and spend less but they
probably ain't gonna do that anytime
soon
but it doesn't say anything about
structurally changing our country it
doesn't say anything about dealing
with racial inequality or sex
sexism in the workforce or climate
change what does that have to do with
the department of the treasury
but what we are seeing guys is that this
thing this thing that is being pushed
into the system under the guise of
diversity and tolerance
is actually a disease that is infecting
the entire
system and if you don't see it
yet i promise you will see it i promise
you we'll see it as they take more money
from your paycheck so that they can do
their pet projects
and as as they make it harder they will
literally make it harder for
white people to get a job like that's
that's actually the end of how this all
works right if you say okay we're going
to help these people do something based
on the color of their skin well you got
to punish somebody else like
there's such a series of these crazy
things out here we're gonna help women
get jobs well that means you're gonna
have to hurt men from getting jobs
and it's like do you guys want to think
about any of these things or do you just
want to say what you think sounds good
so you can maintain power i think i
think i know the answer to my own
question
all right let's move on to segment
number three because this is the big one
of the day because as you know i've been
pretty annoyed at uh the hypocritical
politicians
that we have here in the united states
now virtually all of them happen to be
democrats i would love to find
some that are republicans there's no
doubt that there's plenty of hypocrisy
on the republican side
but lockdowns generally speaking have
been coming to us
from progressive mayors progressive
governors
and state legislators and the rest of it
so over the last couple days i've been
asking people can you just give me a
massive twitter thread about the worst
people right now just the worst people
and you guys know
uh you know i like to talk about uh
ideas more than people right like i try
not to just
trash people out here but i do have one
exception for that which is politicians
if you're a hypocritical politician and
you're destroying people's lives
you personally deserve to be trashed i
don't sit here babbling on about
uh you know lefty youtubers that i
disagree with
or pundits that i disagree with really i
try to talk about the the substance of
their ideas
but these politicians deserve to be
called out by name and they deserve to
be mocked and ridiculed and everything
else so we got a crazy
long thread here of hypocritical
politicians and i want to give a shout
out to mary margaret olahan
on the daily caller because she she had
this threat and then a couple other
people
inserted some other stuff but we're
going with mary's thread
from the daily caller so we're just
going to run through the tweets you're
going to see them all here i'm going to
read every single one of them and just
think
to should these people this is what i
want you to think as i'm reading this
should these people have any power over
your life or not and why do they not
obey their own edicts so here we go
first up is mayor
dc mayor muriel bowser she traveled to
joe biden's victory speech
in a quote high-risk delaware area and
excused the trip by saying it was
essential travel
exempt under dc restrictions she was so
excited that
that biden got elected that she felt
that that was essential even though it
was a high-risk area and she wanted
everybody else to be
locked home in d.c chicago mayor lori
lightfoot she defended her decision to
get a haircut despite urging citizens to
stay at home
in accordance with the state order it's
unclear to me if that picture is from
before or
after the haircut but regardless i would
say she needs a new stylist
uh chicago mayor lori lightfoot here she
is again she told
people to cancel traditional
thanksgiving plans after biden victory
in large crowd of course she was
standing there in the large crowd
because
you know biden winning get out there
don't even wear a mask
talk to the people but can people eat
turkey with grandma no no
no security footage obtained by fox news
shows a wet-haired nancy pelosi walking
through
east salon in san francisco on monday at
308 pm
as she attended her appointment for a
wash and blowout
though indoor hair salons in that
california city were currently
closed yeah pelosi is like the hypocrite
of the hypocrites
why didn't she just have the stylist
come to her six million dollar mansion
she's worth 16 million dollars i don't
begrudge her that as long as she did it
legally although
you know she's a politician and why
should she be that rich is whatever
uh here's my favorite photos show a mask
list gavin newsom during
dining indoors at one of the highest
rated restaurants in the world despite
his restrictive coronavirus
guidelines for the citizens of
california as you guys know that was
french laundry it's crazy
expensive they spent fifteen thousand
dollars
on booze at that dinner yeah really
philly mayor jim kenny dined indoors in
maryland a widely circulated photograph
shows though indoor dining was
prohibited in philadelphia surprise
surprise
governor ralph northam this is the guy
who was in blackface who also talks
about post-birth abortions and got
coveted he was caught masculist
at virginia beach he later apologized
and said i was not prepared
uh bill de blasio one of the worst human
beings on planet earth he goes to the
gym before new york
governor cuomo shut them all down so he
knew they were about to be shut down and
if he felt that it was so important that
we shut them all down maybe he wouldn't
have gone to the gym
but you know do as i say not as i do
dianne feinstein
a california senator who's been in
government for 800 years
she who had pushed for a nationwide mass
mandate she was seen masculist
in public surprise surprise uh here's a
bunch of new york democratic leaders who
were caught masculists at a private
dinner party despite covet restrictions
uh this was a great one there was video
that we showed you a week or two ago new
jersey governor phil murphy confronted
by angry protesters for eating outside
without a mask he then as the women are
yelling at him he puts the mask on
because he's like oh no i got caught
then we have new york governor andrew
cuomo said that his mother and daughters
were coming for
thanksgiving after telling new yorkers
to stay away from loved ones
after a massive backlash his office told
me
the this is by the twi the twitter
person that cuomo will be busy on
thanksgiving and won't be home he
apparently worked on thanksgiving and
didn't see his mother so congratulations
andrew
although i'm pretty sure your father
mario cuomo who was governor
of new york uh two decades ago would be
very embarrassed by you and your brother
uh the governor of oregon who cheered on
the massive black lives matter protests
earlier this year tell citizens to
uninvite members
for thanksgiving so the governor of
oregon and oregon and particularly
portland has become a total hellscape
but you know you can be out there
protesting black lives matter not a
super spreader event no pandemic
uh again you can have your uncle over
for thanksgiving no no no no
uh denver mayor hancock tweeted warnings
to citizens to avoid travel
30 minutes before he boarded a flight
to travel to his family for thanksgiving
okay
he got on a plane and left to be with
his daughter for thanksgiving 30 minutes
after he said that you can't do it i saw
this one yesterday
san jose mayor sam licardo attended a
thanksgiving party with family members
who were not part of his own household
after telling citizens to cancel big
gatherings this year hypocrite
los angeles county supervisor sheila
cool we talked about her yesterday she
dined outdoors
only hours after voting to ban outdoor
dining the vote was three to two
she was the third vote to crush 31 000
restaurants
in los angeles which are not open right
now absolutely insane
california lawmakers they traveled to a
conference in hawaii despite new
coronavirus restrictions as if
california is not nice enough they
couldn't find a nice place
maybe in malibu to sit outside they had
to take it to hawaii
good god pelosi again she cancels dinner
for new
democrats after blow back over her
coronavirus risk they were going to have
this indoor dinner that got cancelled
but she thought it was okay until the
outrage nancy pelosi wipes her nose
touches podium
house members demonstrate the wrong way
to wear masks by the way you see this
with chuck schumer all the time
constantly touching his face and then
touching podiums and all sorts of other
stuff
mayor london breed who dined in a
semi-enclosed room at french laundry
that fancy french laundry up in northern
cali
restaurant three days before she banned
indoor dining in her city that's the
same restaurant of course that
newsom infamously dined at and finally a
texas
judge to plead guilty pay fine after
violating his own
stay at home order i have no doubt guys
that there are plenty more
of these stories but the point is how do
you
want to live these people have decided
that they have the power over you to
tell you how to live
but i'm going to go out on a limb here
and say that you know how to live better
for yourself you know what choices to
make you know if you're around elderly
family members
or more high-risk people or people that
have other diseases
or all sorts of stuff or you have young
children who are at school and you don't
want them to be with grandma whatever
those sys
whatever that reality is for you i have
a feeling that you know how to live your
life better
the idea that we've outsourced any of
our sense making to these people
that we have said to these people you
can keep us trapped in our houses you
can keep us away from our businesses
you can actually infringe on our ability
to do that very special thing right that
that very special thing that's
guaranteed
to us the right to pursue life liberty
and the pursuit
of happiness because happiness is a
pursuit it's something you got to do for
yourself
the government can't just hand you
happiness the same way it can't just
hand you
safety okay you cannot do that and we
must
push back because the window is closing
guys the window is closing
when you see that we have a government
that wants a potentially
incoming government that wants to come
in and deal with
racial equity and gender equity
and all of these things and then they
have big tech and then they'll start
telling us you're not allowed
to tweet anything anti-lockdown and then
there'll be nobody to fight back right
because the republicans didn't do
anything
did absolutely nothing and you know my
more libertarian side what did i want
the government to do i'm not even
totally sure
i did start a tech company in the midst
of all this to fight back because i
believe you got to figure out some
things to
for yourself but we have a big problem
we have a giant expanding government
potentially on the horizon with big tech
that's out of control with some of the
worst anti-american ideas right on the
horizon
and it's up to you it really is up to
you that's the only way we win this
thing
we win this thing by you standing up and
fighting back and figuring out how you
want to live
in the midst of all this mess because it
truly feels this is what it feels like
to me that the american experiment
is is on trial right now and what type
of person are you going to be
as the trial is happening are you going
to be someone who stands up
for what you believe in or are you going
to belie or are you going to be somebody
who just cows in silence and watches all
your freedoms
and the the incredible hard-fought
spectacularly wonderful freedoms that
our ancestors have fought for are you
just going to watch them go away
it's up to you it's up to you i think
you know what i'm going to do guys
reminder that
part two of my conversation with douglas
murray just went up this morning
and the full thing is up already at
reubenreport.com and it's really
incredible because douglas
who you know uh is an incredible
conservative thinker and writer from the
uk he spent about three months
in the united states and he traveled
believe it or not with antifa at times
up in portland he went to trump rallies
i went to one with him
and all sorts of stuff and he gives uh
his
his expert take uh or his expert
diagnosis
on what's going on with america so we
put that up this morning you can check
that out
uh and just one more reminder if you
join reubenreport.com just in the next
couple days as
we're closing out for the year uh we're
gonna we're gonna give you
either a reuben report t-shirt or a
reuben report mug all you have to do is
become a paid subscriber at
reubenreport.com
and then email support reubenreport.com
with your username
and we will hook you up thanks for
watching everybody
the craziness ain't going anywhere and
neither am i i'll be right back here
tomorrow
at 11 a.m pacific 2pm eastern
tata